l'eufor est lâché le fleuve
le voici il ne vous tuera quel est le
genre de personnage que vous interprétez
les temps pour l'instant je suis voué au
dur au coeur tendre si vous voulez quoi
des zones d'action avancées tellement
méchant maintenant ça commence a dévié
sur sur un côté plus humain si vous
voulez je vis d'une façon tout à fait
normal c'est à dire je me confortent
dans la vie communs comme un bon père de
famille j'ai des loisirs qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ce que vous pourriez penser
c'est à dire j'aime lire j'aime écouter
de la musique je me fais même la nature
enfin d'autres choses quoi
figurez vous que les vedettes de cinéma
elle aussi prennent des vacances et
aujourd'hui nous sommes venu surprendre
en plein inactivité notre grille
nationale lino ventura au cas bref comme
vous voyez une journée de vacances de
lino ventura ressemble étrangement à
n'importe quel jour des vacances de
monsieur tout le monde
dans le fond ces gens là ne sont pas
tellement différents de nous